nouveau numéro de reporter sur france24
direction les états unis où le droit des
femmes à avorter est de plus en plus
restreint tout récemment la fuite d'un
document confidentiel a confirmé la
volonté de la cour suprême à majorité
conservatrice
d'annuler une jurisprudence qui
garantissait depuis 50 ans l'accès à
l'avortement dans tout le pays si cette
décision est confirmée d'ici quelques
semaines elle aurait un impact sans
précédent sur les 75 millions de femmes
en âge de procréer aux états unis la
moitié des états à majorité
conservatrice se disent en effet prêts à
interdire immédiatement l'avortement
dell annonce de la cour suprême et de
fait la situation est déjà compliquée
pour les femmes comme au texas où dans
l'oklahoma en duplex des états unis on
retrouve pierrick laurent correspondant
de france 24 pierrick vous avez tourné
ce reportage avant la fuite des
documents confidentiels de la cour
suprême américaine qu'est ce qui vous a
alerté sur ce sujet mais en réalité la
situation actuelle est le fruit d'années
de mobilisation sur le terrain et auprès
des élus en particulier des élus
républicains de ce qu'on appelle la
droite évangélique conservatrice vous
allez en voir certains de ses
représentants dans ce reportage il ya eu
aussi des indices très clair d'un
changement très profond sur le terrain
ces derniers mois en particulier au
texas donc où la loi et ce billet est
entrée en vigueur en septembre dernier
elle impose de très fortes restrictions
sur le droit à l'avortement et puis
début avril toujours au texas et une
jeune femme de 26 ans qui a été arrêté
emprisonné au mépris d'ailleurs de la
loi locale pour avoir pratiqué un
avortement sur elle-même en feng donc
cette décision attendue de la cour
suprême et qui est toujours en suspens
on va découvrir votre reportage donc sur
ce droit menacé à l'avortement aux états
unis reportage que vous avez tourné avec
valérie defert et puis on vous retrouve
juste après pierrick
[Musique]
chaque matin c'est le même rituel devant
cette clinique d'avortement
ce sont les meilleurs au centre de la
terre on
les adore
suzanne à une parade infaillible pour
faire barrage aux anti avortement qui
campent sur le trottoir
elle couvre le bruit des manifestants
puis je vous donnais cette bible le
pardon est possible même après un
avortement chaque voiture est prise en
étau entre d'un côté les manifestants et
de l'autre les bénévoles en gilet arc en
ciel bon la jeune fille du mississippi
il venait prier avec notre pasteur
bonjour je suis avec la clinique je ne
suis pas avec ces gens là bas
susan est ce qu'on appelle dans le
jargon une escorte
elle accompagne les femmes qui viennent
se faire avorter pour les protéger et
souvent les rassurer
vous allez voir ils vont commencer à
créer mais je vais vous parler de
n'importe quoi de la météo de vos
chaussures juste pour couvrir leur fuite
la roumaine clinique de tout ça est l'un
des derniers centres d'avortement encore
ouverts dans l'état de l'oklahoma mais
la majorité des patientes viennent
désormais de l'état voisin le texas où
depuis l'automne dernier l'avortement
est interdit après six semaines de
grossesse même en cas de viol ou
d'inceste
dès le 1er septembre lorsque la loi est
entrée en vigueur
notre volume de patients a doublé voire
triplé nous recevions d'habitude une
vingtaine de patients par jour et
maintenant on est à 40 60 patients par
jour
du jour au lendemain l'oklahoma est
devenu un refuge pour les texanes qui
veulent avorter comme sierra 18 ans
cette lycéenne qui cumule deux emplois
pour aider sa famille a fait six heures
de route de nuit après sa vacation chez
amazon
c'est parce que je suis juste à la
limite le coeur ne bat pas encore mais
je suis à cinq semaines et six jours
ces dernières semaines ont été dures
pour mon corps je n'imagine pas vivre
cela pendant neuf mois
sa cousine l'ailé a tenu à l'accompagner
elle est le seul membre de sa famille à
être au courant elle a regardé des
millions de cliniques étage elle m'a
appelé en pleurs parce qu'elles étaient
toutes complètement bouquet on
n'arrivait pas à trouver de rendez vous
et certains effets très cher elle était
très stressé en colère
et les partage son désarroi à 19 ans
elle est devenue maman il y à un mois
rizwan je n'ai pas pu me faire avorter
parce que lorsque j'ai réalisé que
j'étais enceinte l'interdiction et
venait de passer au texas
donc je n'ai pas pu me faire avoir
je n'ai pas de voiture donc je ne
pouvais pas voyager donc j'ai dû le
garder
sierra a dépensé 250 dollars pour
l'essence et l'hôtel
et la pilule abortive coûte en moyenne
600 dollars et n'est pas remboursé par
l'assurance santé aux états unis dans la
salles d'attentes des dizaines de femmes
espèrent pouvoir se faire avorter
tiffany l'infirmière en chef fait des
heures supplémentaires depuis des mois
pour tout les recevoir
mais nouveau coup dur pour le personnel
de la clinique l'oklahoma vient tout
juste de passer une loi calquée sur
celle du texas et avec effet immédiat
démoralisés tiffany ne sais pas comment
l'annoncer à ses patients je dois leur
dire désolé les filles peut rien faire
aujourd'hui la loi viennent pas c'est
l'avortement est désormais illégal
on parle de femmes qui ont voyagé du
texas et du kansas de l'oklahoma de
l'arkansas deux parties est désormais où
vont ils aller pour se faire avorter je
peux compter sur les doigts d'une main
le nombre de cliniques en les étalant
tôt c'est complètement dingue hansen et
le gouverneur de l'oklahoma va encore
plus loin à partir du mois d'août
pratiquer des avortements sera
considérée comme un crime passible de
dix ans de prison et de plusieurs
milliers d'euros d'amendé
c'est profondément découragement
la vérité c'est que c'est démoralisant
et on sait que des femmes désespérées
vont faire des choses des soldats et des
femmes vont mourir
à l'extérieur pro et anti avortement
sont plus que jamais divisée
et la tension monte rapidement
tout ce qu'elle veut c'est crier
mépriser la vie de cet être humain parce
que c'est un être humain
ce combat idéologique est devenue en
quelques décennies une croisade
politique
ronald regan a été un des premiers
gouverneur du pays à légaliser
l'avortement dans son état la californie
en 1967 six ans avant la jurisprudence
movie wade qui rend l'avortement légal
au niveau fédéral mais pour s'assurer de
remporter l'élection présidentielle de
1981 regan veut mobiliser le vote
évangélique il fait alors volte face et
se déclare entier à bord te ment
depuis les républicains ont gardé cette
ligne idéologique en 2016 pour se faire
élire donald trump a promis aux
évangélistes de faire interdire
l'avortement
donald trump tient sa promesse et
pendant son mandat il nomme trois juges
à la cour suprême où les conservateurs
sont désormais majoritaires pour la
première fois depuis 50 ans
l'institution se déclarent favorables à
l'annulation de la jurisprudence rovi
wade ce qui donnerait le pouvoir de
décision à chaque état et 26 états
conservateurs se disent déjà prêts à
immédiatement interdire l'avortement
dès l'annoncé de la décision de la cour
suprême
les états unis deviendrait alors un
désert médical pour les femmes qui
souhaitent apporter
une réalité déjà tangibles dans
certaines parties du pays comme au texas
à houston depuis plusieurs mois la
clinique du planning familial est
complètement vide le personnel se
contente désormais d'aider les patients
à voyager
depuis que la loi est entrée en vigueur
nous sommes souvent obligés de refuser
des patients et de les aider à quitter
l'état les patientes ont déserté les
lieux depuis l'entrée en vigueur de s by
eight surnommée la loi du battement de
coeur elle interdit l'avortement dès qu
une pulsation est détectée soit vers six
semaines de grossesse lorsque la
majorité des femmes ne savent pas encore
qu'elles sont enceintes ce que vous
voyez sur l'échographie ce sont les
pulsations de ces luttes qui deviendront
par la suite un coeur mais il ne s'agit
pas encore d'une activité cardiaque
pourtant cette loi dit que si on
aperçoit ses battements cette personne
ne peut plus apporter au texas et c'est
très triste de le dire aux patientes
alors qu'elles sont prêtes à recevoir
leurs soins
sur les 40 cliniques d'avortement au
texas il n'en reste qu'une vingtaine
d'ouverte mais les évangélistes sont
bien décidés à bannir totalement lives
et g
et ils ont fait du texas un laboratoire
des idées les plus conservatrices
mark lee dixon les tests sur le terrain
ce pasteur de 36 ans a participé à
l'élaboration de sb ait une loi
redoutable car elle contourne la justice
fédérale en donnant le pouvoir aux
citoyens
le mécanisme de surveillance citoyenne
signifie que n'importe quel citoyen peut
attaquer aux civils toute personne qui
pratique un avortement
ou est d'une famille
en cas de condamnation le délateur
reçoit dix mille dollars de
dédommagements
marc a repris ce même principe mais au
niveau local
depuis deux ans il parcourt le pays de
ville en ville pour inciter les
municipalités à passer des arrêtés pour
interdire totalement l'avortement centre
ville a voté pour mais on a aussi et
j'espère que ce soir marque elle
adoptera
ses arrêtés interdisent l'avortement dès
la conception contrairement à la loi sb
mythe qu'il interdit seulement après
l'apparition d'un battement de coeur
[Musique]
il
ce jour là il vient convaincre le
conseil municipal de marck et texas 250
habitants
[Musique]
depuis le 1er septembre
aucun bébé n'a été avortée dans l'état
du texas gloire à dieu pour ça mais la
vie commence à la conception d'ailleurs
le parti républicain du texas encourage
sur son site les villes à passer des
arrêtés qui interdisent totalement
l'avortement
nous n'avons pas de climat qui si vous
savez c'est donc une mesure préventive
tout à fait
l'année dernière l'administration biden
s'est engagé à donner un accès à
l'avortement dans toutes les villes du
pays de brisach quatre marques espèrent
aussi bloqué l'offensive de
l'administration byden qui a dérégulé la
pilule abortive désormais accessible par
courrier désormais seul vers ces arrêtés
garantie que la pilule abortive
soient considérés comme de la
contrebande
elle ne pourra même pas être envoyées
par la poste
à l'unanimité la bourgade de marque et
devient un sanctuaire entier avortement
je suis contre l'avortement je suis
vraiment contente qu'il soit venu et
qu'il met contacter car je pense que
c'était la volonté de dieu
marquez est donc devenue la 48e ville
dans le pays à interdire purement et
simplement l'avortement et la 43e au
texas
même si robert suez n'est pas annulée
nous avons déjà trouvé le moyen
d'arrêter l'avortement et s'il faut le
faire ville par ville et c'est ce que
nous ferons
[Musique]
sur tous les fronts l'offensive anti ivg
gagne du terrain aux états unis
[Musique]
après avoir considéré l'accès à
l'avortement comme un acquis les
démocrates tente de contre-attaquer
avec 61% de la population favorable au
droit à l'avortement les démocrates
espèrent désormais mobiliser les
américains pour les élections de mi
mandat
et on retrouve pierrick laurent le
correspondant de france 24 aux états
unis pierrick vous évoquez à la fin de
votre reportage chez pilule abortive qui
peuvent être envoyés à domicile par la
poste est ce que c'est une solution pour
les femmes qui vivent dans ces états où
l'avortement pourrait être prochainement
interdit c'est clairement la solution la
plus simple la moins coûteuse cela évite
de prendre des jours de congé pour
voyager à l'autre bout des états unis
pour des femmes disent d'ailleurs
souvent dans n'ont pas les moyens de
prendre ses billets d'avion de prendre
ses chambres d'hôtel alors ces pilules
il faut rappeler elles sont très sûrs
jusqu'à dix semaines de grossesse elle
représente déjà d'ailleurs la moitié des
avortements pratiqués aux états unis
alors du coup des ong comme et d'access
basé en autriche en voit désormais ses
pilules depuis l'étranger dans des états
où elles sont interdites après six
semaines comme au texas se pose tout de
même ensuite la question du suivi
médical écouter ce qu'en dit christie
pitney de l'association aides access
donc que nous avons interrogés
vous pouvez toujours aller aux urgences
et dire que vous pensez avoir fait une
fausse couche les mêmes ça les gens
pourraient avoir peur de le faire
maintenant donc le risque c'est que les
personnes restent à la maison même en
cas de problème donc ces restrictions
sont dangereuses et elles n'auront pas
l'effet espéré par les politiciens de
réduire le nombre d'avortements
ça va juste augmenter le nombre de
patients obligés de voyager dans
d'autres états de commander des pilules
sur internet est tout simplement sortir
du système de santé un moment où l on
aurait vraiment besoin
alors qu'eric ce qui est étonnant c'est
tout cela se déroule alors que les
démocrates sont au pouvoir comment se
fait-il qu'il soit incapable d'agir
d'abord il faut rappeler que les
démocrates ont une responsabilité
historique dans la situation actuelle
dans ce qui se passe en ce moment en
cinquante ans il jamais fait passer de
loi au niveau fédéral pour garantir
l'accès à l'avortement ce droit il ne
repose donc que sur cette décision de la
cour suprême qui est révocable alors
aujourd'hui joe biden n'a pas vraiment
de marge de manoeuvre la majorité
démocrate au sénat est bien trop étroite
pour faire passer une loi avec les 60
voix requises une tentative a encore
échoué d'ailleurs quelques jours
seulement seul espoir finalement pour
les démocrates c'est que leur électorat
se remobilise fortement grâce à la
menace qui pèse sur ce droit à
l'avortement cette question elle
pourrait bien servir de catalyseur c'est
en tout cas ce qu'espèrent les
démocrates pour les élections de mi
mandat à venir au mois de novembre
pierrick qui le rend à los angeles pour
france24 merci pierrick c'est la fin de
ce magazine merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi et on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour
le reporter sur france 2
[Musique]